human history has been full of battles
and Wars some big and some small but if
World War three were to happen it might
be humanity's biggest battle yet
advanced technology massive troops and
more intensive strategy would all be
involved but why would something like
this happen what countries would join in
and how would this war be fun this is
what if and here's what would happen if
we had World War 3 people have talked
about a possible world war 3 for decades
it almost started in the 1960s during
the cold war between Russia and the
United States but thankfully we managed
to avoid that but let's say we aren't
lucky enough to avoid it next time when
might World War 3 happen well it's tough
to say a world war could start due to
prominent political figures getting
killed
intelligence threats or fighting over
valuable resources talking about it like
this makes the chances of a war
happening sound likely but the chances
are actually a lot lower than you think
since 1945 the world has seen many
different battles Vietnam Afghanistan
and dozens of different civil wars we
should keep in mind that in order for a
world war to happen it needs to involve
the entire world and the structure of
the world has changed even more since
1945 countries simply aren't as closely
allied as they used to be militaries are
even stronger and more skilled than they
were as in previous World Wars it's most
likely that millions of people would die
and the earth would take decades if not
centuries to recover
especially with some of the weapons and
tools countries would be using in
today's age soldiers on the ground might
have exoskeletons these are metal frames
around the soldier's body that augment
their strength although this probably
won't turn them into robocop it would
make it easier for soldiers to carry
heavy equipment over long distances
weapons that can bend around corners
might also be a possibility and instead
of seeing the war fought in the sea or
the sky it could actually be fought in
space militaries could fight over
weaponized satellites that could affect
what's below them although a lot of this
stuff sounds like something out of a
sci-fi movie we should keep in mind that
these weapons are scary and hopefully no
one will ever need to use them after all
things like this are meant to kill
people but there may not be many
soldiers on the ground the war of the
future might be fought on computers
drones artificial intelligence and
robots could be the only things on the
battlefield there's also a chance that
acts of war in the future might not
involve any violence at all hacking into
other countries computers as well as
power grid shutdowns are all a
possibility and what would this war be
about anyway it could have to do with
resources specifically water since fresh
water is such a scarce yet valuable
resource nations may begin to fight over
it as it continues to deplete hopefully
World War three won't go on forever so
how could it end
well one reason and a main reason why a
world war hasn't happened yet has to do
with these things during World War two
the United States dropped nuclear bombs
of Japan killing over 100,000 people the
cities involved took decades to recover
but the two nukes used in World War two
would pale in comparison to the modern
nukes we have today oh and by the way
there are nearly fourteen thousand
nuclear warheads around the world held
mostly by America Russia and China a
nation can have all the resources people
and strategy they want but if a nuke
gets dropped on them then it's game over
and if one country drops a nuke what's
to stop another country from doing the
same and then another and another and
soon the world would be destroyed so who
would win this war absolutely no one a
full-on world war 3 would have a massive
impact on the world as a whole it's safe
to say that the world would never be the
same but try not to lose sleep over this
after all
a third world war like this with dozens
of countries involved is incredibly
unlikely to start tomorrow if two
countries get into a fight it's more
likely that other countries that aren't
directly involved will stay that way and
let the other nations fight for
themselves wars are terrible let's try
to avoid them after a heavy subject like
this I need a bit more fun I know what
if we jumped into a pool full of stomach
acid hmm may not be fun but that sounds
like a story for another what if
you